the time has come for me to yield the
floor now our next MC is a man who has
more rings on his fingers than I can
count more laughter in his heart that a
dozen comics more talent than a room
full of Award winners the man who made
candy men and tootsie rolls a national
craze the mad hugger himself Sammy Davis
jr.
thank you very very much my father
thanks you my uncle thanks you and I
thank you and I would especially like to
thank the Academy for having me back
again in this tabernacle of seer now if
you happen to be a real film freak like
me and my wife say we run movies every
night this has got to be the last game
of the World Series the Kentucky Derby
the Super Bowl and of course my old
family heirloom the Davis Cup
if you know give you cats don't laugh
nobody gonna know what ain't true as
many times I've been on these shows I've
never been I've never been this move I'm
killing the band if I can only get the
audience as I've been tonight I mean
standing oh I was over there yeah
standing over there hearing that list of
46 award-winning flicks man that's heavy
you know as JJ would say dynomite we
gotta prove that we're the daddy of them
all right and we are but don't let
anyone tell you any different at any
time I mean because real quality lasts
now someone might ask what's quality it
could be a line of dialogue a special
effect a certain creation of another
time or another place a song a gesture a
bit of business a dance scene so
skillfully done that they make you cry
or they make you laugh now before we put
the next Oscar up for adoption let's
take another look at some of the golden
boys home movies and see who and how
some of the ancestors were distributed
the winner is the winner is Frank
Sinatra
Donna Reed Edmund O'Brien miss Shelley
Winters
Rita Moreno Margaret Brotherhood the
winner is
Marlon Brando on a man yoni its
yumminess
Elizabeth Taylor Sophia Loren great
Patricia Neal
wendy hiller in New York is Charlie
booth the winner is William Holden Grace
Kelly and his partner Jack Lemmon
Dorothy Malone Katharine Hepburn love
their chosen Heyward Charlton Heston
Maximilian Schell and cross to be 14
Julie I'm Lee Marvin Miss Elizabeth
Taylor
Alec Guinness the Monsignor egg
well let's try me
may I just say something I am so proud
in what of a small way to be a part of
this industry and like That's
Entertainment said boy do we need us now
I would dislike I had to say it because
I just feel that way thank you everyone
for allowing me to be a plan to
celebrated survivors of the towering
inferno they're getting together again
to present the next award he's the
player who holds the record in rushing
and she's the beauty who has been rushed
into stardom ladies and gentlemen miss
Susan Berkley and the Jews himself Oh
Jay Simpson
it takes imagination skill taste and
talent to provide movies their
atmosphere the tasteful and talented
people who have been nominated and the
best achievements and art directions are
Richard Silbert and W Stuart Campbell
for Chinatown set decoration by Ruby
Lovett
Alexander Golitsyn Andy Preston aims for
earthquake set decoration by Frank
McKelvey Dean Cavalera San Angelo Graham
for The Godfather Part 2 set decoration
by George or Nelson Peter Ellen Show and
John B Mansbridge Walter Tyler and Al
Roloffs for the island at the top of the
world set decoration by hell talisman
William creeper and ward Preston for the
towering inferno set decoration by
Raphael Vuitton okay okay you make these
two points the winners are Dean Cavalera
San Angelo Graham for The Godfather Part
II and for
well I just want to say thank you to
everybody and our construction crew our
painters our greens men our research
department to Francis that's everybody I
can think of I'll go along with all that
and the personal thanks Thank You
members Francis Coppola my friend a man
Angelo and all the hundreds of people
have helped us do our ideas and put them
on the screen and a Joe Chevallier our
assistant in the Sicilian segment thank
you
I would just like to take a moment out
Susan I would like to apologize for
mispronouncing your name I should have
done it right but I ain't this used to
doing this either so I'm sorry but I
it's Susan Blakely ladies and gentlemen